[Music]  this package just came in  [Music]  get everybody out here  play me  [Music]  hello detective banks do you know where  your officers are  jigsaw well i thought that jigsaw killer  was dead  he is  [Music]  find him their hours not days how can i  catch this guy if there's nobody on the  bus  i can fuss you can't do this alone  whoever did this has another motive  something personal  was the last time you saw your father  [Music]  all available units officer down that  was just  an inversion to get us out of the  precinct  i need everyone on this case  it could be anywhere he could be anyone  we're gonna tear this city apart  [Music]  hello detective banks when was the last  time  you saw your father  [Music]  you